[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like the answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and Speaker of amazing facts
welcome listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact on July 30 2016
American Luke Aikins became the first
person to jump from over four and a half
miles up without a parachute and lived
to talk about it in a stunt called
heaven Scent the 42 year old parachute
safety advisor leaped
25,000 feet to earth setting the world
record for the highest jump without a
parachute to accomplish this aikens had
to use the rushing air currents around
him to steer his body and safely land on
a special 100 by 100 foot net suspended
20 stories above the ground near Simi
Valley California
during the 2 minute freefall that
daredevil reads 220 miles an hour as he
neared the ground was only a second to
go he quickly flipped onto his back and
landed squarely on the net without
injury Aikens who had previously done
18,000 parachute jumps said he'd been
preparing for this stunt for over two
years according to Associated Press just
before climbing into the plane to make
the jump safety officials ordered Aikens
to wear a parachute but Aikens argued it
would make his landing in the net more
dangerous and he'd never have a chance
to open it as the plane was climbing to
the drop zone he said the requirement
was lifted and he took off the chute did
you know the Bible says the devil once
tempted Jesus to jump from a lofty
height claiming angels would catch him
stay with his friends we're gonna learn
more as we bring you this edition of
Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
says that's one eight hundred four six
three seventy to ninety seven let's get
to our first Bible question with pastor
Doug Batchelor and our co-host pastor
Jean Ross
will be going to the phones in just a
moment you're listening to Bible answers
live if you have a Bible question lines
are open and
good chance if you call now you'll get
your question on tonight's program and
it shouldn't take too long pick up the
phone for Bible questions 800 God says
that's eight hundred four six three
seven two ninety seven I am Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross good
evening listening frames and pastor Doug
let's begin the program with prayer do
you father once again we thank you that
we have this opportunity to study
together them he asked for your guidance
send the Holy Spirit to be with those
listening be with us Father and lead us
into a fuller understanding of Bible
truth for we ask this in Jesus name Amen
amen
I fasted I opened the program by talking
about this remarkable feat of jumping
out 25,000 miles high thousand feet
sorry yeah four miles that be the movie
25,000 feet out of the plane and not
having a parachute and then trying to
navigate to a well what probably seems
rather small when you're coming down
from that height at that speed atlantean
an ant rather remarkable it's like
trying to dive into a cup of water from
the Empire State Building ha ha and I
did parachute once I did it they they
make you go tandem jumping and so I was
attached to someone but we did get the
feel of what it's like to freefall and
steer your way through the air and we
were up 13,000 feet and for every 13,000
feet you fall for approximately a minute
and I guess he was up where he needed to
start out with oxygen and
deliberately jumped without a parachute
you know during World War Two they say
you can never get me to jump out of a
plane with a parachute
unless the plane was on fire but he
jumped without a parachute and you can
be sure that he had practiced that many
times because he didn't want to be just
empting the Lord I think he had a wife
and family he didn't want to end his
life so he's an instructor 18,000 jumps
he'd practiced but then I teased at the
end of the fact by saying did you know
the Bible says the devil tried to
encourage Jesus to make a high jump
without a parachute you can read about
this in the book of Matthew chapter 4
verse 5 during the three great
temptations that the devil brought to
Jesus it says then the devil took him
into the holy city and set him on the
pinnacle of the temple this is hundreds
of feet up and he said to him if you're
the Son of God throw yourself down and
now the devil quotes the Bible firt is
written he'll give his angels charge
over you and in their hands that will
bear you up lest you dash your foot
against the stone your Satan is only
partially quoting Psalm 91 and of course
Jesus refused to fall for it he said it
is written you shall not tempt the Lord
your God and that when we are recklessly
risking our lives and tempting God you
know the Bible says God has not mocked
what a man says he'll reap and if we
keep pushing the limits got will often
intervene and protect us yeah there's
many times he probably does bear us up
and save us from disaster but if we keep
pushing we will experience the fruit of
our risk and
Jesus said no you don't needlessly risk
your life if something happens God can
intervene but you shouldn't tempt the
Lord and say Lord I'm gonna jump save me
yeah that's a very dangerous thing to do
now some people are facing temptation
all the time not just tempting the Lord
with unnecessary risk but you know we
meet with the devil every day just like
Jesus did how do you deal with
temptation maybe you're struggling as we
all do with temptation friends and you'd
like to know more about how can I have
the victory are there any tips any clues
to gaining the victory over temptation
Jesus of course used the Word of God we
prepared a book that has 12 of the most
popular biblical suggestions for how you
can successfully resist temptation maybe
you're needing freedom from some habit
this book has the tips and the guidance
to help you get a new life the book is
called tips for resisting temptation and
we'd like to give this to you for free
all you'll need to do is give us a call
on our resource phone number and the
number is
885 six seven four seven you can answer
the book called tips for resisting
temptation that number again is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and if you have a Bible question
the phone line here to the studio is
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven it's eight hundred God says
for sixty three seventy to ninety seven
well I think we're ready for our first
caller we got Kevin listening from
Edmonton Alberta Kevin welcome to the
program oh yes hi thanks for taking my
call yeah I just got a question and then
I got a super quick question the first
question is um
regarding and in the New Testament it's
Jesus and I know the paschal say the
saying is uh Jesus who said and that the
right hand of the Father now is that a
symbolism or is that an actual thing cuz
I'm thinking it's more of a symbolism
since Jesus's you know the Word of God
so maybe that being in in his right hand
but I was hoping maybe clarify that well
it I believe that Jesus when it says
he's at the right hand I think that if
there's a geographic position for the
throne of God next to the Father it
would be at his right hand right hand is
symbolic also in the Bible of a position
of favor or prominence when a king sat
on his throne often the
second-in-command would be at his right
hand and it might be his heir it might
be prime minister but whoever was second
in power would sit at his right hand
typically most people in the world are
statistically right-handed it is their
stronger hand so in the Bible you'll
always hear it referring to the right
hand as a sign of favor
and but there you know a lot of places
it it talks about the right hand the
matter of fact I think the phrase right
hand is found I just did a quick search
a hundred and fifty eight times in the
Bible so when it says Jesus was seated
at the right hand of the Father I
believe there was some form of
Coronation after Jesus returned from the
earth victorious and he was sat down and
you know he was declared victorious over
the devil and having his mission of
redeeming the earth and you know
probably sat literally at the Father's
right hand during that time but it does
symbolize something in the Bible too so
you know you're right on both counts
okay perfect and the quick question I
have is regarding your news flash I
always see I guess I saw a couple of
those but they're pretty old I'm just
wondering if you guys are doing anything
more like that or you just stopped no
working out well yeah sometimes we do
get behind us because of travel
schedules and and right now I don't want
to just do a news flash unless I think
there's something worthy
I'm probably not going to delve into
talking about what's happening
politically in North America because
religion is already divisive enough but
we are looking right now at doing a news
flash of prophecy news flash on
Christianity and Islam and just some of
the issues that are coming up right now
so yeah I'm glad you're watching we're
going to be doing some new ones okay
I'll keep my thanks what hey thank you
appreciate your call Kevin a
next koley's o Mara Mara Mara Marla who
is listening from Redding California
Marla welcome to the program
great now you're up and reading and
you're getting us on KFI a that's great
good reception
okay yeah and I actually
I'm on the phone and my my radio doesn't
work oh okay
that's fine in your question tonight yes
yes so I do have a question regarding
Daniel 2
verse 34 and 35
and I think it's also in 44 and 45 and
it is a stone coming out of a mountain
and I'm wondering if there is a
connection between Matthew 13 that's
also talking about the end of the world
verse 39 and
343 all right well let me read this and
you wanted me to read me Daniel chapter
2 verse
34 you said yea 34 and 35 all right let
me read this for our listeners you
watched while a stone was cut and of
course friends this is the image that
King Nebuchadnezzar dreams about and
Daniel has the same dream then he
interprets what the dream means and he
says you watch while a stone was cut
without hands which struck the image on
its feet of iron and clay and broke them
to pieces now let me just pause and say
something about that real quick Marla
the Hebrews were not to build idols the
whole vision that represents the
kingdoms of the world is a great Idol
it's talking about you know a false
structure
God's altars when they built it out of
12 stones they were not to lift up their
tool on it because they'd be tempted to
carve it into animals or something and
just take rough stone and without being
cut by man's hands and so when it says a
stone cut without man's hands it's also
Unruh lusion to what Moses said about
when you worship God don't don't lift
your chisel upon it and
it says that verse 35 and the iron and
the bronze and the silver and the gold
were crushed together after the stone
falls upon them became like the chaff
from the summer threshing floor it's and
hot and dry and light and blows away
saying all the kingdoms of the world
will not exist but the kingdom of God
stone grows into a great mountain fills
the earth meaning the kingdom of God
will ultimately triumph blessed are the
meek they will inherit the earth pastor
also then read the corresponding verse
in Matthew
you know what pastor I'm gonna read
another verse just before we get to the
one in Matthew because I thought of
something while you were talking I Jesus
actually refers to this imagery of a
stone and he connects it to his second
coming in Matthew chapter 20 verse 43
Jesus said there for us and here the
kingdom of God will be taken from you
and given to a nation bringing forth the
fruit thereof and then verse 44 jesus
said whoever falls on this stone will be
broken but on whomever it falls it will
grind him to powder so there's a direct
reference to you what you read there in
Daniel chapter 2 about the stone
representing the kingdom of God striking
the image and grinding all the metals to
powder I think it's interesting parallel
there and your other reference you said
was in Matthew was it 24
it was Matthew 13 sorry Matthew 13 39 is
that
let me let me read a little bit of this
it says the field is the world the good
seed are the sons of the kingdom but the
tares are the sons of the wicked one the
enemy who sowed them is the devil and
the harvest is the end of the age and
the Reapers of the angels therefore is
the tares are gathered and burning the
fire so it'll be at the end of this age
yeah so that you they're both talking
about a judgment marla but you know one
is the stone judging the kingdoms of the
world and if we're not part of God's
kingdom we're judged and just like the
chaff and also like the weeds or the
tears that are gathered and burned so is
that where you're wondering about the
correlation
yes I'm wondering because in in the in
the process harvest happen and then
threshing happens and so I'm trying to
understand if this is a physical
if this isn't a judgment that actually
happens like it says he that is unjust
let him be unjust still he that is pure
and so forth when that happens way
before he comes and so my questions
related to the way the Bible seems to
put it in an order like first there's a
harvest the angels like so without him
like you so succinctly is dead it's like
it's not you know anything man is doing
this is God so if the angels can be the
ones that are separating chaff from the
wheat that looks like a judgment it
possibly I mean I'm not sure yep
when you see in both in Daniel 2 and in
Matthew 13
it's it's talking about the judgment the
metaphor of a harvest is used even in
Revelation Jesus is pictured coming with
a sickle to harvest and it talks about
not only the harvest of wheat it
compares the judgment to the harvest of
wine it says you know that the if we've
all heard that song glory hallelujah
trampling out the Grapes of Wrath which
is a quote from the Bible and so a that
was the end of the farming season was
the harvest and Jesus and the apostles
and prophets often talked about the
judgment the end of the the season of
farming jesus said I'm sowing the good
seed it's a word of truth and then
there's a judgment at the end of time so
yeah you're on the right track that I
wanted put too much into the order of
you know the angels in the mountain and
trying to correlate all those because I
think these are just sort of sweeping
metaphors of Jesus used but the angels
of course they are participating in the
in the judgment and in the redemption
and rescue of God's people before the
the final fires fall
alright well thank you for your call
Marla and we're gonna move to our next
caller we have Micah listening in Miami
Florida Michael welcome to the program
hello pastor dr. Ross
yeah I guess let's get straight to it my
question I suppose is a bit
simple and bit broad but recalling a
verse that says that if any men sink
East and
I think he goes if I'm in think east and
let him take heed lest he fall and
just touching on another subject I know
that the whole idea of one stays always
saved isn't really truth or it really
some scripturally based anyway my
question is questionably how this one
will have assurance in salvation like
how can one have insurance evaluation
well sometimes it feels like it's like
every time I want to feel assured if you
will there's always like something new
to think about if you I don't know that
makes me sense no I think it does there
there's really a balance first of all
how do you how can you know the Bible
says that just we'll live by faith and
so it's by faith that we believe and we
are saved by faith and
at the same time the Lord doesn't want
us to have a presumptuous or a reckless
faith most of our faith is based upon
some evidence I mean even David when he
went out against Goliath he had faith he
could kill a giant but one reason he had
faith he said well you know I had to do
this once with a bear and again with a
lion he said in the side but have faith
to believe the same God that helped
deliver me from a lion and a bear can
help me with a with the Giant so he had
faith but it was based on evidence our
faith is based on the evidence of God's
promises God promises if we repent and
confess our sins he is faithful and just
to forgive us and cleanse us from all
unrighteousness
we believe his promise said if we
continue to abide in him he will not let
go of us and that if we follow him that
he will lead us all the way he's the way
the truth and life and so it's a faith
in Christ that he'll finish what he
started in your life
so that gives us assurance
because I read another course I believe
in the general epistles of John
it mentioned something about how our
hearts can judge us
all right and I was wondering if like
sometimes it seems like a you know where
you I would want to have
you know in terms of my character it
seems like sometimes like oh I don't
feel like I'm ready or worthy I'm once
again I'm not sure this is making any
sense because I'm stammering here but no
I I think I know what you're saying John
makes the statement about if
if our hearts don't condemn us we have
peace with God and you know some might
substitute the word conscience there you
know very before conscience is always
bothering this how can we have peace
with God and and how can we have faith
and how can we have assurance you know
pastor like we have a book just looking
at through our free library and it's
book cold a sure and it deals with us
called justification made simple and I
think Michael you'll enjoy it all you're
left to do is just call us on our
resource phone number after the book
written by pass that I'd called
assurance a lot of Scripture references
there the number to call is 883 five six
seven four seven you can ask for the
book a game called assurance 808 three
five six seven four seven that is the
resource phone number and the phone
number here to the studio is eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven eight hundred four six three
seventy two 97 with your Bible question
Annex Holly is Robby listening from
Huntsville Alabama Robby welcome to the
program oh yes thank you for my phone
calls I question I was wondering and
want to find out if the Jews the sort of
Israel will they be able to be saved and
go into the seventh if they do not
accept Jesus as Lord and Savior and
Messiah and the son of God
well obviously there's going to be Jews
in the kingdom that you know from the
time of let me just clarify something
when we talk about the children of
Abraham there are many children of
Abraham they were not Jews they were
Hebrews technically all Muslims are
children of Abraham but from the time of
Jacob he had a son named Judah Judah
became one of the big tribes Jews were
technically the descendants of Judah but
most people say the word you now to
encompass anyone from the 12 tribes of
Jacob
from the time that God made the promises
to Abraham Isaac and Jacob there was a
lot of Jews that never they didn't live
during the time of Christ they'll be
saved by faith looking forward to the
coming of the Messiah there may be some
Jews that will be saved that lived after
the time of Jesus that did not accept
Jesus because they didn't know he can
even see during New Testament times not
everybody had the internet and I think
in the book of Acts chapter 19
there were 12 Jews living up in Ephesus
that had been baptized by John the
Baptist but they hadn't heard about
Jesus yet and after Paul preached about
as to them they were baptized and filled
with the Holy Spirit and so but Jews
from the time of Christ they're not
saving any differently than anybody else
in other words God doesn't have like
three levels are three different kinds
of rules for salvation we're pagans are
definitely going to be lost without
Christ they just go directly to hell
without passing go Jews well they're in
kind of a limbo condition because
they've got some Jewish DNA they they
get a pass even though they don't accept
Jesus it doesn't work that way if the
Bible says God is no respecter of
persons it doesn't matter whether you're
Jewish in tile they're going to be there
were people at the foot of the cross Jew
and Gentile saved and lost you know what
I'm saying and so it it's all based upon
does a person believe in the gift that
God gave nobody is saved by virtue of
their blood or their DNA
God has made of one blood all nations
now God made a promise to the Jewish
nation
but he wasn't saving them he often
delivered them as a nation but
individuals within that nation could
still be saved their loss based on how
they follow God
does that make sense
a question and I guess
I've pondered it quite a bit not just
saying thank you for the opportunity to
finally get some light and clarity and
thank you so much and God bless you and
Shalom to your ministry well thank you
and we've got a book we'll send you that
talks about this it's called spiritual
Israel we'll send you a free copy if you
ask the number to Coley's eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
you can ask for the book called
spiritual Israel again that number eight
hundred eighty five six seven four seven
and the phone line here again in the
studio is 800 four six three seven two
nine seven we've got Keith listening
from Alaska Keith welcome to the program
um thanks
chapter nine verse two
okay we're going there now and what is
your question do you want us to read
them it speaks of the altar of since
behind the curtain
for that let me read this and I'm
reading right now from the New King
James Version and it says for a
tabernacle was prepared the first part
in which was the lampstand the table the
showbread which was called the sanctuary
and behind the second veil the part of
the tabernacle which is called the
holiest of all in which was the golden
censer and the Ark of the Covenant
overlaid on all sides with gold and
which was a golden pot and it had the
manna that's talking about the Ark so
you're wondering and when people read
this typically they're wondering I
thought that the altar of incense was in
the holy place the first compartment and
here it seems like Hebrews and Paul is
saying that the altar of incense is in
the second compartment is that what
you're ready
well I tell you the altar of incense had
handles on it and whenever they were
ministering before God the priest would
put incense on the altar once a year on
the Day of Atonement they actually
carried the altar of incense in or
pushed it in I don't how they got it in
there inside the veil maybe the priest
did it because it was only like one
cubit by one cubed and whenever they
ministered before the Lord there was
incense on the altar and so on the day
of atonement
better known as Yom Kippur the altar
would be found in the Holy of Holies in
Hebrews when Paul is talking about this
he's often speaking in the context of
the Day of Atonement so that's the
answer that I've heard from good
scholars both Christian and Jew
through the year the altar of incense
was gonna be in the holy place the first
apartment right by the curtain on the
day of atonement it was pushed through
the curtain as the priest went in to
minister he always had incense becoming
before the Lord so
that's the answer that's been given me
and I've been satisfied with it how
there is that what you've heard pastor
Ross it's right yep the connection
between the ultra typically for most of
the earth that appears of the altar of
incense was just before the veil yeah
that separated the holy from the most
holy the also close connection between
the function of the altar of incense as
it relates to the most holy place where
the incidence was offered and wafted
over into the most holy place sometimes
the altar was associated more with the
most holy place with reference to
function then the holy place so that's
another reference as to why they in this
description in Hebrews it's placed in
the most holy place by the ark yeah and
even just the practical side of the
sanctuary services in the wilderness
they were dealing with a portable tent
when Solomon built the final temple or
the the main most glorious temple it was
a little more elaborate matter of fact
the ark sat under the ark had two angels
on the top but also in Solomon's Temple
it sat under two gigantic angels that
wings overspread the ark place so it was
a beautiful spot with even more
information or more glory and probably a
little more sophisticated when Solomon
built his temple the pastor Ross we have
a lesson that talks about God drawing
the plans and we'll be happy to send you
that Keith all you have to do is call
amazing facts and that number 883 five
six seven four seven we'll send to the
lesson God drew the plans more Bible
questions coming pick up your phone and
call
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
I
really wanted to start a new devotional
habit but life got in the way next thing
I know we're a month into the new year
and I'm like what's the point of
starting then I saw 365 amazing answers
to big Bible questions each day is a
single study so you can start anywhere
on any day and not miss a thing they're
crisp clear and enlightening
get yours today by calling 855-578-6767
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live
we still have a few phone lines open if
you have a Bible related question call
us at one eight hundred seven
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven now let's join pastors doug
batchelor and john ross for more Bible
answers live
welcome back listening friends if you
have tuned in somewhere along the way
you are listening to Bible answers live
it's a live international interactive
Bible study program we're all part of a
big Bible study family and we enjoy
visiting with you every week we do have
a couple lines open if you want to
participate with a Bible question or
some question about living the Christian
life we'll do our best to search for the
answers together the number 800 god says
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven that's eight hundred four
sixty three seventy to ninety seven i'm
doug batchelor my name is john ross and
we gonna go to the next caller we have
Edward who's listening in gold
California I add word welcome to the
program you're on the air
well let's just be clear about what
we're answering the word rapture means
to be caught up with power
sometimes a person might say I was in
rap glory with listening to the music
means I was just caught heavenward in
the glory of the music and
will there be a rapture before the
second coming the Bible tells us in
first Thessalonians chapter four it's
really clear the Lord Himself will
descend from heaven with a shout with
the voice of the Archangel and the Trump
of God and the dead in Christ will rise
then we which are alive and remain will
be caught up
now that's the rapture right there we'll
be caught up to meet them and in the air
and so shall we ever be with the Lord
and so it is at the Lord's coming we are
caught up and it's really clear dead
rise it's a resurrection the trumpet the
second coming trumpet the day of the
Lord is is in a-comin were caught up to
meet him and so
we don't believe that there is a
seven-year tribulation between the
rapture and the second coming that is a
fairly popular new belief when I say new
I mean if you read Christian literature
from the time of Christ until a hundred
years ago all of the scholars and
theologians and preachers believed that
the second coming of Jesus was when we
were caught up and the idea of there
being a seven-year tribulation before
after the rapture rather is a fairly new
belief and came out of Darby ISM I still
believe the old belief I think as pastor
Det Jean does that
there is a tribulation but the
tribulation comes before the second
coming and part of the reason for that
is Bible says it is through much
tribulation we enter the kingdom of God
there's no promise that the church is
not going to experience any tribulation
God saved Israel not from the ten
plagues but through the plagues that
fell on Egypt and God is going to save
his church when Jesus comes through the
seven last plagues he protected them but
they were in Egypt when the plagues came
and God will protect us when plagues
fall in the world so jesus said he that
endures to the end will be saved indoors
what these tribulations so
did I don't know if that's helping
answer your question Edward
yeah well I'm not at all worried about
the tribulation I I just want to be
faithful you know God promises he'll not
allow us to be tested above what we're
able but with every temptation he'll
provide a way of escape I'm not so
worried about you know how will I endure
the last days as I am I endure being a
Christian tomorrow I just want to be
faithful day by day and if we're
faithful in little things the Bible says
he that is faithful in that which is
least will be faithful also in much you
know we have a book called the secret
rapture and it actually gets right into
this and explains what the Bible has to
say about the second coming I'll be
happy to send this to you Edward or
anybody who calls and asks the number to
call is 883 five six seven four seven
that is a resource line you can answer
the book called at the secret rapture
again that number is 885 six seven four
seven I next call is thanks Edward our
next hole is Rick and he's listening in
New Jersey Rick welcome to the program I
had a question about king Saul okay when
King Saul went disguising himself with
went to the Witch of Endor and he wanted
to speak to Samuel and Samuel came from
beyond the grave and we're told of salt
at the next day knowing as a Christian
well knowing that's wrong to go to
meetings and Psyche so whatnot I also
wonder why God allowed
Samuel to return from the dead to speak
to us all and that in Danni counter well
I don't believe it was Samuel I know
pastor Ross knows
there's another verse I think it's in
chronicles where it talks about Samuel
Insull
based on what you see happening in this
story and from our friends that are
listening you find this at the end of
1st Samuel just before King Saul dies he
goes to a witch and the which conjures
up supposedly the ghost or the spirit of
Samuel well the devil doesn't have power
to call God's prophets back to life
but the devil does have power to create
illusions the Bible talks about lying
spirits and evil spirits that work
miracles and and we have every reason to
believe this was a lying spirit yeah
that was impersonating
just like the devil will impersonate
Christ this was a lying spirit that was
impersonating Samuel the Prophet yeah we
have a verse in 1st chronicles chapter
10 verse 13 where it's talking about
soul and it says the soul died for his
transgression which is committed against
the Lord even against the word of the
Lord which he kept not and also for
asking counsel of one that had a
familiar spirit to inquire of it so
there it refers to it as being a
familiar spirit it's not it's not a
prophet Samuel but it is an
impersonation of Samuel and familiar
spirit in the Old Testament is really a
demon or a devil masquerading as a dead
loved one a person well I was
yeah when I was growing up the big thing
back then was to do a seance and see if
we could conjure up you know go through
these incantations and I was not a
Christian back then and we would try to
conjure up these famous people from
history and we all were like trying to
talk to Abraham Lincoln or Houdini or
Napoleon or somebody and and boy I tell
you what all the seances going back then
I don't think that Lincoln and Napoleon
could have kept up with all the
appointments so you know the Devils were
creating illusions and they're moving
things around and supposedly speaking
through people and that's why god
forbids that he said if you want a
message why would you talk to the dead
if you want a message a divine message
then you speak to the Lord and you ask
the Holy Spirit that God guides you we
don't consult dead people and when Saul
did that he had already grieved away the
Holy Spirit
so yep well we have a lesson to talk
specifically about this and it's called
are the dead really dead and it talks I
think about the Witch of Endor mm-hm the
number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven you're gonna answer this
study guide called are the dead really
dead again that number is 885 six seven
four seven I next call is Virginia
listening in California Virginia welcome
to the program
yeah I was in Calimesa or down near
there just yesterday this morning a
matter-of-fact
wonderful
my question is free in regards to in
Romans 3:28 I've been reading about the
law and
in regards to the state without the
deeds of the law is
I was reading like in March I mean
chapter
324 by the law is the knowledge of the
earth
[Music]
talks about in Chapter six for sin shall
not have dominion over you for ye are
not under law but under grace what is
all this talking about oh that's a great
question you know first of all don't
feel bad if you're a little bit confused
about this some of the the deepest
theology and all the Bible is in Romans
chapter five through eight and Paul is
speaking in very lofty terms first of
all when Paul says were not under the
law he of course does not mean that
Christians are under no obligation
to obey the Ten Commandments because you
would never hear Jesus say now that
you're Christian you can lie and kill
and steal when he says you're not under
the law he means the the penalty for
disobedience is sin he says this in
Romans chapter six wages of sin is death
when we accept Jesus we're no longer
under the penalty of the law
so Paul is talking about through grace
we are saved from that penalty of death
we are no longer under the death penalty
of the law and we now keep the law not
to be saved but because we love the Lord
and we are saved that's why Jesus said
if you love me John chapter 14 keep my
Commandments and so it's now out of love
the law shows us our sin nobody's saved
by the law the law is really there it
stands - you know highlight our sin I
remember when my kids were young and
they weren't brushing their teeth
correctly the dentist gave them this
toothpaste and they brush with this
almost like a fluorescent toothpaste and
it made any plaque in their mouth turn
bright pink and they could then look in
the mirror and grin and say wow look at
all these spots I'm missing and you know
they kind of thought it was neat but
then it made them feel guilty because
it's not I'm not brushing very good well
the law is there to help us recognize
our need
of
God's power to to live a holy life we
can't do it without his power
so you know Paul says the law is just
and holy and good now we've actually got
a book that explains this whole subject
yeah the book is called does God's grace
blot out the law and that's dealing with
Romans chapter 8 we'll be happy to send
this to you Virginia anybody wanting to
understand this passage it's an
important passage three the number to
call is 808 three five six seven four
seven you can ask for the book called
it's got a long title does God's grace
blot out the law and we'll send that to
you for free again 800 eight three five
six seven four seven as for the book
does God's grace blot out the law and
we'll get that in the mail to you hey
Thank You Virginia and in that lesson by
the way you can read that book online at
the amazing facts website which is as
you would guess amazing facts dot o-r-g
dot-com net TV there's a lot of ways to
go there amazing facts a just google it
and you'll see our youtubes as well but
we have that book in our free library
does God's grace blot out the law you
can read it there annex Foley's Sarah
listening from Orlando Florida Sarah
welcome to the program hi thank you so
my question is about the Sabbath I know
the Sabbath is Friday sundown to
Saturday sundown and
and we're not supposed to work on the
Sabbath and I don't want to work on the
Sabbath because I want I do want to show
god I love Him by obeying his command
but I don't have a college degree and
it's hard to be able to provide for
myself and pay for rent and things like
that and so I'm about to get offered a
position where I'm gonna have to work on
the Saturday on the Sabbath a lot is it
okay I know the Bible talks about you
can do good on the Sabbath so would this
be considered ok since I'm doing good as
far as being able to provide for myself
and be self-sufficient
well now let's talk about that for a
second are the commandments optional
and you know we if we're not careful
Sarah we can probably rationalize
anything I've actually heard men's well
I know it says don't commit adultery but
I'm out on the road on business trips
and God knows and you know man's got to
be a man and and they start
rationalizing that there's you know
times when a little bit of adultery is
okay and I'm gonna know
and I don't think his wife would
understand that either so when God says
this is my day and I want you to rest it
doesn't mean you'll never be tested
there are times when we're gonna be
tempted to lie to try and you know cover
up something order to make life easier
for ourselves or whatever it is you know
we might be say I'm a little older than
I am so I can get the Denny's discount
and just so there's always reasons to
rationalize and this may be a test Sarah
and I was in the same boat as you were
you know I had a family and when I
learned the Sabbath truth I thought I
got this great job offer I thought boy
and they said you only have to work for
six months on Sabbath
in order you get seniority so you won't
have to you can pick your schedule I
thought well I can't I said it's like a
commandment of God and I said I can't do
it and you know what I think of Sarah
went and I know that might seem like
kind of an austere answer but you know
the story in the Bible where
Shadrach Meshach and Abednego
the king said everybody bow down to this
Idol and if you don't bow down to the
idol not only will you be unemployed
you're gonna die and
Shadrach Meshach and Abednego could have
said well idolatry is just a little
thing I mean I'm just bowing to I could
tie my shoe I just pretend I'm bowing
down but really just be tying my shoe
everything and they wouldn't bow down
they wouldn't even look like they're
bowing down when the music played and
everyone bowed down they stood up
because the commandment said you're not
to pray to idols you'll not bow down to
them and they got thrown in a furnace
but God protected them and he saved
their lives and they said even if God
doesn't save our lives we're gonna obey
His commandments same thing happened to
Daniel in Chapter six he had to choose
am I going to close my windows and
pretend I don't worship God anymore and
that I'm praying to the king and the
first commandment said don't have other
gods he said no I'm not gonna close my
windows I'm gonna go to the lion's den
and so you're facing a similar test now
and if you believe in your heart that
the ten commandments are not just
suggestions that they are commandments
of God you might have to have faith and
say Lord I'd like a miracle right now I
need this job but I want I want to put
you first ya know if you're still
struggling about whether it's true or
not that's a different issue but when
you know you know Cena's going to do
good not doing it yeah I think one of
the things that's making me doubt is
you know Jesus talks about it's okay to
do good on the Sabbath so that's why I
was thinking well I am doing good by
being able to provide for myself you
know a place to stay and food and
whatever so that's why I guess I that's
what's got me if you can you explain
that what are the things that okay to do
good then on the Sabbath well would you
that's a good question whenever Jesus
did good on the Sabbath he was healing
people teaching people you never found
Jesus in the carpenter's shop earning
money he because you know today that if
the commandment is specific about
anything it's a day not to do room
unitive labor where you're working for
your living god says six days thou shalt
labor and do all thy work and so what
you're talking about right now is a job
that involves your work and he said what
the seventh day that's a holy
appointment for us it's it's holy to the
Lord you know can you let us send you a
free study guide on that Sarah yeah
that'd be great thank you so much and
yeah it's called lost a lost in history
yeah lost day off of histories what the
study guides called yeah you just call
this number we'll send you a free copy
and we'll give you a website for anyone
who's asking these questions a lot of
Christians are asking about the Sabbath
truth yes absolutely to receive the
study guide just call us on our resource
phone number it's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven you can
answer the study guide called the last
day of history but even I guess better
than this study guide all it's a great
study guide is our website called
Sabbath truth comm which has got the
study guide plus a whole lot of
additional resources that I think you'll
find very helpful as air as you study
this further just go to Sabbath truth
com
thank you so much all right thank you
we'll be praying for you I next holy is
David listening from Brooklyn New York
David welcome to the program
hello hi David you're on
hi pastor doug and pastor ross
concerning some of the plagues there are
in the book of Revelation I've been
reading on the internet all over the
internet and YouTube
there's a whole bunch of people that
believe that this year there's going to
be a crippling financial crisis and
nobody's gonna have money in the bank
and that you know everything is gonna be
chaotic and that that's going to be
followed by
martial law throughout the whole United
States I
know you well do you think that's
possible and could that be some of the
first time I heard that was in the 80s
and I had a lot of friends they said you
know that there's going to be a meltdown
and they're getting their building POWs
camps for American citizens and yeah all
your money out of the bank and its it's
been forecasted almost every year for
years now someday that will happen
but I think we've got to be careful not
to be living on pins and needles and
biting our fingernails and fretting I'm
I know that a lot of people said
including that Pastor John Hagee that
there was going to be these blood moons
last September and the whole world was
gonna implode and Israel was going to be
attacked and the banks were gonna crash
and and that'll probably happen someday
but none of it happened and so I know
folks that have lost a fortune cashing
out all of their CDs and they lost all
this interest because they got scared
and and and none of it happened I know
other people that have they've sold
everything and they've moved out to the
country and they don't have a job and
they just thought you know you have to
live off the land and and then pretty
soon they find winner comes they not
really ready for country living and and
they come they've lost all their equity
I think you gotta be careful just to
really make sure the Lord is guiding you
if you read the internet you're gonna
find first of all if you got an ache or
pain don't go to the internet because
you're gonna think you're dying I'd be
hurt I look in the internet I said oh
man I've got some disease I can't
pronounce I didn't realize I had there's
probably just a headache but
you're gonna find everything on the
internet so you got to be careful it's
it's kind of a tree of good and evil the
day is gonna come David the plagues are
gonna fall I can't predict it's gonna be
this year things in the condition in the
world right now are looking very dire
things
religiously it looks like tensions are
mounting with threats of war and
terrorism
economically it doesn't look like it's
stable but I I think you've got to
occupy Jesus said you know we've got to
stay busy until he does come and
right you know being a Christian is not
just about trying to save yourself it's
about wanting God to use you to reach
others and you know I remember reading
about when the bubonic plague went
through Europe there were so many
Christian missionaries they said we only
the plague is in that town we're gonna
run and save ourselves and some of the
missionaries said we're gonna go into
the city we're gonna help the people
with plague or leprosy and they expose
themselves
so
yeah there's gonna be a hard time coming
so what can we do to win souls in the
meantime
that's that's the big question
yeah don't know when it's gonna come
don't believe everything you read on the
Internet hey you know birds were falling
out of the sky and they say that that's
a plague and then they say an asteroid
is gonna hit the earth any day now and
and that's the flaming mountain of
Revelation
you know what I mean so
be careful you don't talk about pastor
Ross hey absolutely there's no end of
rumors and interesting interpretations
of prophecy along to the verse in the
Bible that says no prophecy is of a
private interpretation so we need to let
the Bible interpret itself you can look
at these symbols and apply all kinds of
things but having said all too that I
think the Bible is also quite clear that
we need to be ready we need to have that
connection with Christ for no man knows
the day or the hour and these things can
come rapidly the final events we believe
will be rapid yeah Jesus said in such an
hours you think not the Son of Man comes
anyway hope that helps a little bit
David we appreciate your call and we do
have that book anything but secret you
would enjoy and I'm gonna call for that
is 883 five six seven four seven you can
ask the book called anything but secret
let's talk about the second coming again
800 eight three five six seven four
seven a facet I'm wondering do we have
time for another caller we're looking at
our look engineer two and a half minutes
here let's try was all right we've got
Caleb listening in Michigan we have
about two minutes Caleb okay great
my question is about eternal security
once saved always saying if you become a
child of God and that son should be
revoked and
if you choose the waves of this world
over the ways of Christ and ms the way
the truth and the light yeah we believe
the Bible teaches that you're always
free to choose the Lord he will never
let go of you but we don't lose our
freedom to turn away from him there are
many examples in the Bible of believers
that did turn away and so you know Judas
once walked with the Lord and he was
full of the Holy Spirit and some would
argue well he never really was saved
well Jesus sent him out preaching and
miracles were done through him the King
Saul was filled with the Holy Spirit and
he prophesied Balaam was a prophet all
of them are lost and because they turned
away and you know we have a book called
can a saved man choose to be lost and
we'll be happy to send it to anybody who
calls and asks again it's eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
you can ask the book can a saved man
choose to be lost no Caleb I hate to cut
you short and listening friends if we
did not get your call tonight please
give us another chance God willing we
will be back with more Bible questions
and Bible answers and don't forget to go
to the website amazing facts not o RG
now before you sign off we've got
another amazing facts coming so stay
tuned
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
can't get enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge 24 hours a
day seven days a week right from your
computer or mobile device visit aft vor
G
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at
WWF AG 0 RG and sign up for our free
Bible study course and make sure to
check out our online bookstore at AF
bookstore comm which offers thousands of
inspiring books DVDs and more to help
you get the most out of God's Word to
take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at
$887
RG did you enjoy this program make sure
to tell your family and friends tune in
next time for more Bible answers live
honest and accurate answers to your
Bible questions
[Music]
friends have you ever heard of the
bowhead whale this enormous Leviathan is
the second largest creature in the world
dark and stocky it roams the fertile
Arctic northern waters these massive
creatures can be more than 65 feet long
and weigh more than 75 tons that's
heavier than the Space Shuttle yet in
spite of their Titanic size they're able
to leap entirely out of the water can
you say belly flop the bowhead whale
gets its name from its bow shaped skull
and they've got one ginormous noggin
matter of fact their heads are about 40%
of their body size which comes in handy
when you find out how they use their
heads they've got very thick skulls
sometimes they get trapped under the
surface and they use their heads to ram
the ice they can break a breathing hole
in the ice that is a foot and a half
thick friends you have to just imagine
what it would be like to be walking
around on the Arctic ice and all of a
sudden have the ground beneath you crack
and split and rise as one of these sea
monsters pushes its head up to breathe
for the first time in 90 minutes
because bow heads make their home in the
coldest part of our world they have the
thickest blubber of any whale but this
plus they're friendly and curious nature
made them prime targets when the
European whalers discovered the bow
heads they hunted them nearly to
extinction
fortunately because of conservation
efforts we've slowly seen their numbers
begin to increase since the 60s one of
the most amazing facts about the bowhead
whale is its longevity
scientists have discovered by evaluating
harpoon tips found in their skull and
examining their eye tissue there are
bowhead whales out there that are
probably over 200 years old you realize
that means there are bowhead whales
swimming the oceans right now that were
alive before Abraham Lincoln was elected
president can you imagine that
among the other amazing mega facts about
the bowhead whale is its mega mouth they
have the largest mouth of any in the
animal kingdom and when they open their
pie full extended its large enough to
park a medium sized SUV inside yet in
spite of the fact they've got such big
mouths they survived by eating the very
smallest creatures in the ocean plankton
krill and other microscopic animals
friends I'm always amazed by the
creatures God has made this bowhead
whale is able to dive to the deepest
oceans they can break through the ice
and move mountains with her head and
completely leave the water and fly
through the air and yet they do all that
by gaining strength from almost
microscopic organisms helps us remember
that we survive through the little
promises in God's Word Jesus when
tempted by the devil he called just a
few little verses and he sent the enemy
running you can also have that same
durability in long life as the bowhead
whale by trusting in God's Word and his
promises
for over 50 years amazing faxes shared
the wonderful news of salvation and
provided millions of Bible resources to
people all over the world we build
churches in India proclaim God's Word in
China and have sent free Bible studies
around the globe today's program and
free resources were made possible by our
ministry partners caring individuals
like you if you've been blessed by
amazing facts would you please consider
partnering with us to reach others with
the Bible truth your financial support
today will help keep programs like this
on the air so the blessings you've
received can be shared with others to
find out more about becoming a ministry
partner please visit our website at
amazing facts PO RG
[Music]